nehmt euer umfeld genau unter die lupe
im grunde ist das ein welt kinofilm hat
auch in dieser funktion auch in diesem
jahr im frühling das wichtigste
filmfestival bewältigt haben
eine weitverzweigte familie kommt
zusammen
am weitesten angereist ist laura ihre 16
jährige tochter ihre innere bei und
ihren kleinen sohn
was ist denn am ende des abends steht
allerdings ein schock denn irene die
tochter von laura ist plötzlich
verschwunden
richtig voll werden bestimmt einen
komplexen unter den gästen
ich muss so schnell wie möglich kam wir
machen alles andere ist nicht
mitgekommen was sofort ein bisschen
gerede hervorruft in dem dorf er wollte
doch unbedingt dabei sein aber im
letzten moment ist mit der arbeit was
dazwischengekommen arbeitet etwas
anderes als wenn man viel um die ohren
jeder glaubt jetzt wird zu wissen über
lauwarm dadurch andere und jeder glaubt
zu wissen über die familie verdienen
gerade genug um den kredit zu bedienen
also dass am anfang am anfang noch
anfang das war vor zwei jahren
dafür müsste ich auch denn am nächsten
tag kommt eine nachricht irene ist
entführt worden jemand fordert 300.000
euro lösegeld für irene sie ist meine
tochter und deshalb entscheide ich was
zu tun ist
das will ich so ein fiasko farhadi ist
das der erste finden in spanien gemacht
hat er ist ein iranische regisseur der
2011 mit dem film nader und simin eine
trennung international bekannt wurde
allerdings geht es auf vhd datei gar
nicht so sehr in erster linie um einen
kriminalfilm odom eines thrillers ist
ein mitglied der familie nicht das wäre
was verwechselst du bist dann bleibt ist
der sohn eines bediensteten im grunde
nur eine art von vorwand um immer tiefer
in die geheimnisse wie der titel des
films schon andeutet dieser familie
einzudringen das geld muss her und zwar
schnell
und wie sollen sie etwas stehen jetzt
unten erwarten so vielleicht etwas geld
kann aber eine gewisse weise steht
hinter seinem werk die vermutung dass
das was sie in familien geschieht oder
was in sozialen verhältnissen geschieht
in allen ländern der welt oder auch in
allen kulturen dieser welt im grunde
gleich hilfe sein
die finca zu verkaufen aber alle haben
genug aufzulösen insgesamt denn das was
ein offenes geheimnis ist in dem film
ist eben tatsächlich eine sehr sehr
vielschichtige verstrickung von zwei
familien miteinander das ist in dieser
liga das geld abzuknöpfen sehe ich mich
gezwungen alles da
man so sagt anna loos spielt ein
bisschen stärker psychologischen ich
gelogen und mein mann ist bescheid
wehren ich habe hier bei dem diese nicht
um typische spanische präsident viriler
sanftheit in den film einbringt das hat
sich ich hab hier gespielt versicherte
ich glaube das ist wesentlich dass
zentrale talent von asghar farhadi dass
er eben familien geschichten erzählen
kann in denen sich die sozialen
verhältnisse eines landes sehr
interessant und sehr präzise wieder
spielen anschaffen oder was
ist der hintendrauf nicht ein es ja aber
wer ist die spinnerinnen die fährt ich
würde auch insgesamt sagen dass das ein
sehenswerter film ist der vielleicht
nicht ganz die künstlerische reife der
iranischen beiträge von farhadi hat der
das aber mit tollen darstellern und
einer wirklich spannende
familiengeschichte
doch auf jeden fall auf müssen
[Musik]